welcome this video is designed to show
you how Google cloud certifications can
allow you to demonstrate your skills
boost your career and thrive within the
partner program will review the partner
exclusive benefits available to help you
prepare for becoming Google cloud
certified Google cloud is the fastest
growing cloud with significant
advantages in big data processing and
analytics at scale whether you're just
beginning your career in cloud or have
more experience with other cloud
solutions validating your technical
expertise by getting a Google cloud
certified will help you demonstrate that
you have the critical skills to drive
business success in today's highly
competitive market the Google cloud
certification program includes two
levels of certification professional and
associate the associate certification is
focused on core Google cloud platform
technology and is a good starting point
for those who are new to cloud in
general or new to Google cloud platform
specifically the professional
certifications our job role based
certifications and assess at fan's
design and implementation skills develop
through hands-on experience these
certifications are focused on the core
job roles and cloud infrastructure data
and machine learning application
development networking and security now
that we've covered the basics let's talk
about the steps and partner exclusive
resources available to help you prepare
for your google cloud certification your
professional experience is the most
critical part of the preparation journey
use the available exam guides to gauge
how your skills and knowledge match up
to the job skills that will be evaluated
in the certification exam we're
delighted to provide you partner access
to hands-on labs and on-demand training
courses
we also recommend taking the practice
exams that are available for our
certifications these practice exams will
familiarize you with the types of
questions you may encounter on the
certification exam and help you
determine your readiness or if you need
more preparation or experience you can
find all these partners specific
resources including webinars partners
certification kick-start promotions and
other events on the Google cloud partner
portal
we also recommend checking out some
additional resources like our google
cloud documentation pages or the Google
cloud platform YouTube channel for
videos and tutorials on Google cloud
products and solutions we encourage you
to visit the Google cloud certification
website for more information and take
the first step to earn your badge and
become Google cloud certified thanks so
much for watching we look forward to
seeing what you accomplish with your
next Google cloud certification
[Music]